The sharks are back,
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
Where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Are you currently
selling this anywhere?
Well,
we're a pre-revenue startup.
Something smells
a little funny here.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
I won't kill your money.
You've killed a lot of money
before mine.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You know,
nice guys finish last.
You okay?
(crying)
That's not true. Nice guys
finish first all the time.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
Cubes, let me--
Let me jump in there.
Cubes? Just for calling me
"Cubes," I'm out.
It's sink...
I think we can make
something great happen.
Or swim.
Not every football player
in the NFLl's a millionaire.
I could fix you in--in
Darwinian ways you don't know,
but you may not find that
a pleasant experience.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greinier,
the queen of QVC,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew his homegrown
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪♪
Whee!
My name is David Mealy,
and this is
my wife DomiNique.
"Nique" for short.
Look at me!
We live in Tampa, Florida,
with our son Austin,
and we are expecting
our little girl Caroline
in about two weeks.
Nique and I have been married
for five years.
I met her my very first weekend
here in Florida.
I landed a job with actually two
of the largest golf companies
in the country.
But soon after that,
the economy went into the tank.
At that point,
my position was eliminated,
and I lost my job.
We knew we had to come up
with something quickly,
something that would generate
an income for us.
I always wanted to cook.
I wanted to be a chef, actually,
before I got into
the golf career,
so I decided to go after it
to start a little
barbecue catering company,
try to make some ends meet.
We worked day and night.
(indistinct conversations)
Everyone who tried our food
loved it,
but there was one dish they kept
asking for over and over again,
and we knew at that moment
that we had a hit.
And it was kind of that
lightbulb, so to speak.
We're like,
we--we have something here.
Now we really need
the sharks' help
to bring our product
to the masses.
Once the sharks taste
our signature dish,
they are going to love it
and not be able
to get enough of it.
♪♪♪
Hi, guys. My name's David Mealy.
And I'm Nique Mealy,
and our company is back 9 dips.
And this is Caroline.
(giggles)
(sharks chuckle)
We're here today
seeking a $150,000 investment
in exchange for
a 15% equity stake
in our company.
But before we go any further,
we're gonna let you taste
what our company is all about.
Thank you.
Did you know that
over super bowl weekend,
americans consumed over
1.25 billion chicken wings?
And the second most popular
snack food that weekend
was chips and dip.
Well, what you're
currently tasting
is an array of Back 9's
buffalo chicken dips.
We take all-white Meat
chicken breasts,
your wing sauces,
dipping sauces,
blend them together,
creating everything you'd get
in a chicken wing on a chip.
So this is basically
a chicken slurpee?
It's a protein-based dip.
You know, I have to say,
it's delicious.
Thank you.
Do you remember the bassomatic--
You threw a bass in a blender?
(sharks laughing)
You throw chicken in a blender.
(laughs)
I'm visualizing sticking
that chicken in a blender.
(imitates blender whirring)
Mmm! That's good chicken!
No different than
your chicken being chopped up
on your salad
that you have for lunch.
We just grind it up
a little bit and...
(laughing)
It's actually
our number one ingredient.
Kevin, are you crying for...
(laughs) For all those chickens
that lost their lives?
Dave, Dave... (laughing)
When was the first time you
stuck a chicken in a blender?
(sharks laughing)
Hey, I married him
for this dip, so...
He's truly crying.
Oh!
I'm thinking about all those
chickens that lost their lives.
There's only two chicken breasts
per tub, so it's really...
(all laughing)
I-I have to say...
Oh! I'm sorry. (laughs)
(Mark) Oh, man.
(Kevin) Oh!
While they gather themselves,
it...
it really is delicious.
Thank you.
Oh, lord. Sorry.
(Lori) um, okay.
Okay. All right, we're back.
We're back.
No problem.
All right, now we've shed
some tears for the chicken.
Tell me about your business.
After a life-changing event
with me and David,
we went ahead and started
a catering company
called Back 9 barbecue.
And while barbecue was
my specialty,
we quickly became known
for our dips.
So we decided to bring
these dips to retail,
where we built
a very loyal fanbase,
from the college students
all the way to
the Mr. Wonderfuls of the world.
What was
the life-altering event?
Well, last time when I was
eight months pregnant,
David--He had lost his job.
And I didn't have a job, so we
did what a lot of people do,
and we downsized from
a very large, beautiful house
to a very small house.
We have one car now.
We sold off a lot of things
to make sure we kept a roof
over our head.
But it's actually
all worked out...
it's been a blessing.
For the best. It really has
been a blessing.
It was.
So now this is your livelihood,
this business?
It is.
Tell us about
the sales of it.
How much do you sell?
How much money do you make?
We're approaching $400,000
in--in less than 2 years.
We're also approaching
about 400 accounts right now.
We just landed
our first supermarket,
a big chain down in--in Florida.
They gave us a 60-store test.
They gave us a number to hit,
a weekly number.
We're hitting that--
How's it's going?
We're hitting that number daily.
Wow.
Our product--the reason
that it sells so well
is because of the quality
of the ingredients.
People will pay
for a premium product.
That's the biggest reason.
And it's--It's pricey
to put quality ingredients
together.
What does it cost for one?
It retails anywhere from $7.99
to $8.99 for a 1-Pound tub.
And what are
you making it for?
It costs us roughly $2.52,
and I wholesale for $5.25.
And how much do you have
invested into the company?
We got about $150,000 invested.
That takes a lot of guts
when your back's
up against the wall,
to believe in it enough
to build it.
And yeah--and you have--
and you have
another one coming.
And you have children
and another one on the way?
We have a 3-year-old son
and then our daughter
will be here in two weeks,
or sooner
if Kevin keeps laughing.
(laughter)
Pop right out. (laughs)
man, you got a lot
riding on this dip.
Is it always
a positive reaction to it?
Do People ever look at it
and go, "Ew!"?
I think--
I do think at first,
they'll take a sample,
they'll keep walking,
and then they turn around
and they go, "Wait a minute.
"wait a minute.
What did I just eat?
'Cause that was amazing."
And then when people find out
it's a blended chicken,
they don't have a problem
with it?
They love it. Actually, they
gave us really good feedback.
They think
it's a really clever idea.
I agree with that.
I think it's wonderful.
I mean, I really liked it.
I just really wanna go take
another one...
(laughs)
And have it over here.
I also love the two of you.
I think you're both great.
I really, really wanna
help you,
but I'm just not sure
that I'm the right person
to help you get this
into supermarkets everywhere.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Guys, I think you're gonna
do wonderful things,
but I also know that to be
a great entrepreneur,
you have to know
what you're good at
and know what
you're not so good at,
and I'm not so good at
food distribution of this sort.
So as much as I-I love what
you guys are doing,
because it's not a fit and it
doesn't play to my strengths,
I'll have to say I'm out.
I admire your just
stick-to-it-iveness to survive
getting whacked from your job.
This is happening
to millions of americans now.
It's a tough economy out there,
then coming back with something
that's actually working,
you're basically
living off this,
but as an investment
for a startup, basically.
And so there's a huge amount
of risk in it right now.
I could put a royalty on it
and force you to pay me
on every time you sell one,
but that's just cruel injustice
to those chickens
that have given up their lives
in the first place.
(all laugh)
But as an investment...
I'm sorry. I'm out.
You know, I-I loved the story.
I admire what you've done.
Here's the good--
you know the product.
Lori likes it.
I think a lot of people like it.
Here's the bad--
It's a brutal business.
You need a partner that can
help you go down that road.
All I can offer you is--
is advice, encouragement.
But I can't tell you when
to zig or when to zag,
and I think that's what
you really need today.
I wish you the best. I'm out.
I appreciate that.
I appreciate that a lot.
This is a...
very, very hard decision
for me.
There's a guy who came
on the show last year
named big chef shake.
I was in love with him and in
love with the--the concept,
but I didn't have enough
knowledge of the business,
and then he went off and did
$10 million in business,
and good for him.
Absolutely.
Daymond.
You know,
I've been sitting here.
I really like you guys. There's
just something about you.
I would like to come back in.
♪♪♪
Four sharks are out,
but it seems that Lori
is having a change of heart.
Daymond, you know,
I've been sitting here.
I really like you guys. There's
just something about you.
I would like to come back in.
Would you go in with me?
What if we did $150,000
at 25%?
What do you say?
I think we can make something
great happen. I really do.
Wow.
You know, this is making it
very hard,
and I'll tell you
the main reason.
You know,
when I had nothing--
When I had nothing,
and then my little girl--
I had my little girl,
and then my wife was pregnant
with our second,
and then L.L. gave me
that shot,
and he said,
"I'll just invest in you.
"If anything happens,
just take care of me."
And when my little girl was
born, my second little girl,
I was a millionaire.
(sniffles)
You okay?
Daymond,
let's give 'em a shot.
(crying)
(sighs)
It's okay.
(speaks indistinctly)
Lori, I-I was gonna drop out.
This is a very tough decision...
sorry.
Because being as disciplined
as I wanna be as an investor,
I can't bring anything to them.
We'll figure it out together,
and we'll make it a big success.
Look at the two of them.
And it's delicious.
Come on, Daymond.
Lori, I think that they're
gonna do without us,
and unfortunately,
I have to still be out.
(crying)
(sniffles)
Well, I think sometimes in life
you just need a chance.
I'm happy to go in with you,
Lori.
I think that there's people
that just need a shot.
I can't add a lot of value
today,
but I can certainly help you
from a business perspective.
From where you've come
to where you are today,
if nobody ever gave me
a shot in life,
I wouldn't be sitting here,
and neither would Lori.
I'm happy to go in...
good.
At $75,000 apiece for 25%.
Do that?
Yes.
We won't let you down.
We won't.
Come here. Hug me.
(Nique laughs)
You better not.
Sorry I'm so hormonal.
Ohh!
(laughs)
Good job.
Thank you very much.
But you know what I will do?
My card will be there
for you guys and them,
and anything I can do.
'cause I know you guys
are gonna make it. Okay?
I appreciate it.
Give me a hug.
You remind me of my wife.
Oh! She's a good woman, then.
Congratulations, guys.
Good job.
Caroline!
(laughs)
She's going to college.
She's got some new friends.
(laughs)
Everyone needs a chance.
(sniffles)
I can't believe I cried.
(cries)
Last season,
we saw Fleetwood Hicks strike
a half-million dollar deal
with Mark Cuban
and Barbara Corcoran.
For his specialty
bicycle company Villy Customs.
Anyone from ages 8 to 80
can go to our Web site
and create their bike
the way they want it to be.
Let's see what he's up to now.
♪♪♪
Since being on "Shark Tank"
And working
with Mark and Barbara,
everything has been incredible.
Hey, Barbara! How you doing?
Within 24 hours, we had
over 85,000 unique visitors
to our web site.
So we're actually exceeding
projections again this month.
Before "Shark Tank,"
in a year's time,
our sales were $215,000.
And already
in the past five weeks,
we're doing over $100,000
in sales.
We put the $500,000
to great use.
We've hired several employees.
We've completely revamped
our Web site.
We have all also bought
a ton of inventory,
so we're ready
for all the orders.
Being on "Shark Tank"
has really allowed us
to take Villy Customs
to a whole nother level,
and that is awesome.
♪♪♪
My name is Marvin Philip.
I'm from Draper, Utah.
I was drafted to
the Pittsburgh Steelers in 2006.
Three years into my NFL career,
I injured my back.
That forced me out of the game.
(blows whistle)
go. There you go.
Single file, single file.
Come on, low! Try it again.
Let's go zone left.
The best way I knew how to stay
in the game was to coach.
(laughs) Hey!
Whoo!
Pick up your feet!
Because of my back pain, I was
unable to bend over at all.
Even the simplest chores,
like doing laundry,
was difficult.
Ah. Thanks, mom.
I had looked for months
for, you know,
for a simple product
that would help me,
and I was very shocked
to find out
there weren't any products
out there.
And so that's when I decided
to design something myself.
Can you give me your
payment information as well?
Being an entrepreneur
is definitely new to me.
Being able to get a deal
with the sharks
and get that mentor
would be so beneficial to me.
You know, I'm excited to be back
in the game of life.
My new product has definitely
lifted my spirits.
When you see it, you'll be like,
"Man, why didn't I think
of that?"
♪♪♪
Hello.
My name is Marvin Philip.
I am the creator and founder
of the lifter hamper.
I'm asking for $85,000
in exchange for 12% equity
in my company.
In 2006, I was drafted to
the Pittsburgh Steelers
from Cal Berkeley.
In the third year of my NFL
career, I suffered a back injury
that put me of out football
for the remainder of the season.
Not only
did my football skills suffer,
but my laundry skills
suffered, too.
(laughs)
Simple things like bending over
to retrieve clothing
out of the bottom
of the hamper
and carrying
those heavy loads of laundry
from one room to another
became Literally...
(thud)
a pain in my back.
That's when the idea of
the lifter hamper came about.
What the lifter hamper is,
is a bungee spring-loaded liner
that drops as clothes
going in gets heavier
and rises as the clothes
coming out gets lighter,
therefore allowing
the individual
to pick off
the top of the hamper
rather than the bottom.
Now the lifter hamper isn't
just for injured NFL athletes
like myself,
but it's for anyone who
has trouble bending over.
The lifter hamper is for
the 65 million americans
that suffer from back pain.
The lifter hamper
is for pregnant women.
The lifter hamper is for
the elderly--right, Kevin?
(Mark and Robert laugh)
dig him, baby. Dig him.
So instead of having
to put your back into it,
take a load off
and let the lifter hamper
do the work for you.
So who's with me?
That's great.
Can I try it?
Yeah.
Can you put a bottomless amount
of, uh, peanuts in there and...
(laughs)
(laughs) Have it come up.
Can you put it by a bar?
Yeah. There you go, right?
So if I keep
taking things out...
Yeah.
Can I do this?
Yep.
It's gonna just keep coming up?
Yep, and you have
a comforter in there.
And coming up.
Is it working, Lori?
Yeah.
Lori, what is it
made out of?
You know, I don't know.
If feels really cool.
Marvin, do I get
the whole thing?
The--the frame, the cover,
everything?
Yeah. Yep.
Lori, would you buy this
for your house?
I don't know.
I-I think it's interesting.
But how you gonna get that
down to your washing machine?
You're gonna need another hamper
or a basket or something
to go from bedroom or closet
or wherever you have that--
You wheel it. It's got wheels.
Yeah, I didn't see wheels.
So--so as you see
on the bottom,
there's wheels
on the bottom.
It's not wheeling great
on that rug, though.
Can you show it on the wood?
Yeah.
But if you are going
from upstairs to downstairs,
that's not going to be easy
to transport
for the people that need it,
because they can't bend down.
Yeah.
So...
all right, good point, Lori.
This needs some perfecting.
See, that's what
I'm looking for.
I'm looking for a mentor to
advise me on what I should do
and what the next step
should be.
How long have you been
doing this?
Uh, six months.
Oh, that's all?
Yeah.
You--You--
It's kind of impressive.
You know a--you know
a fairly large amount
of the business
in six months.
I'm trying.
Marvin, your company is not
worth the value of $700,000.
Now either you got hit
too many times,
or you really have a lot
in sales.
Actually, we haven't
hit market yet.
(Mark laughs)
(Daymond and Kevin) Whoa!
But--One second--
we have signed two contracts
with two
of the biggest rep firms.
Rep firms? Not a store?
Yeah. And we have contracts
with Amazon and Overstock.
We had one with Costco.
We had to scale back
'cause we couldn't fulfill.
But, Marvin, this is
an agreement, basically,
with the rep company,
and they're just saying
they can maybe get you into
Amazon and Fred's and Costco
and these places.
So yeah--
But--but there's nothing saying
that they did it.
This is just like
a "We'll try it." That's it.
The big question
on that, Lori, is,
are they charging you
up front?
No. They get commission
on the back end.
Marvin,
to the Pittsburgh Guy.
(laughs)
Give us the economics.
What does it cost to make one?
Um, what--what are you selling
for wholesale? Retail?
Okay.
It costs about $10 to make,
and it retails for $49.99.
You have a patent
on this thing?
We were provisional, and then
we just filed our utility.
How much money
have you invested so far?
$75,000.
What did the money go to?
To the tooling,
the patent, and design, you
know, to get it to this point.
Is that a lot of money for you?
Yeah, you know,
not every football player
in the NFL is a millionaire,
you know?
And So, uh...
you know, it is.
No, I didn't--I didn't mean
to be disrespectful.
I'm just--you know,
I just wanna understand
how committed you are to it.
This is my full-time job.
I'm committed.
And--and you know what?
It means a lot to be because
I suffered a back injury,
and I still have trouble
bending over.
And so I've benefitted
from it.
And so, you know,
that what's what I wanna do,
is help other people.
You know, there's millions
of people out there
that can benefit from it.
Marvin,
I like it, actually.
I've herniated two disks
in my back from sports,
and so I know exactly what
you're saying.
And--and believe it or not,
I do do my own laundry.
You know,
I've had to deal with it,
but it's just not an area
where I have connections.
Just to say,
you know what?
"This is a great product.
Place this product for Marvin,
and--And go sell it for us."
Mm-hmm.
So for that reason, I'm out.
So, Marvin,
here's the good news.
I gotta tell ya,
I think it's a clever product.
Here's the bad news--
You've got a long way to go.
I think you just gotta go out
and sell some.
It's Sunday, baby.
You gotta go play the game.
You gotta go out
and knock on doors
and ask for an order--
Not a rep firm,
not some guy for you.
But I think you can do it.
I don't think you need
the money.
You just need the effort.
I'm out.
Okay.
Appreciate it.
Marvin...
my heart is in,
and I love you,
but my gut tells me
you're, like, halfway there.
You have issues,
things that I've brought up
that you need to work on.
Mm-hmm.
And so I'm out
with my money,
but because my heart is in,
you can give me a call...
sure.
When you're ready...
okay.
And I'll be there
to help you.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
I'm out, though.
Okay.
I was waiting to hear
what miss QVC was going to say,
because to me, this is
a very visual, tactile,
demonstratable product
on television.
I would think she'd jump
all over it and in it, frankly.
(laughs)
But it doesn't sound like
she's there,
and I'm a little surprised.
I don't think it's investable,
Marvin. Not right now.
And it certainly isn't worth
$700,000.
I'm just a disciplined investor
trying to go to bed
richer than I woke up, so--
aren't we all? (chuckles)
Well, I think that's what
makes America great.
Yeah.
But I'm out.
Thank you.
Marvin, you come in here,
and you're
a very, very nice guy.
I think
we're all rooting for you.
You know, you're an athlete
who learned the business
in six months.
But on the other side,
I mean,
you're really a shark
because you're offering us 12%
of a company that really doesn't
have much at this moment.
And, you know,
nice guys finish last.
I'm out.
Thank you. Appreciate it.
(Mark) Good luck, Marvin.
(Lori) Good luck. Keep thinking.
Thank you.
(Robert) Hey, Marvin,
that's not true.
Nice guys finish first
all the time.
There you go. (laughs)
There you go.
Me not getting a deal today
will--
Will make me work
that much Harder
to get this product out there
and--and take
the necessary steps to, uh,
to make it a household name.
♪♪♪
Next in
are the Fleming brothers
with a product they believe
will make life a little easier.
My name is Brian Fleming,
the handsome one.
And I'm Kevin Fleming,
the smart one.
Our company is bag bowl.
♪ Bag bowl ♪
♪ bag bowl ♪
we are seeking $40,000
in exchange for a 33% stake
of our company.
After
a thorough design process,
we have perfected
an exoskeleton
that provides structure
to the amorphous blob that is
a standard 2-gallon,
1-gallon, quart,
and sandwich-sized
zipper bag.
By inverting the top
of the zipper bag
and sliding it down
the sides of the bag bowl,
consumers can create
a handy and sturdy bowl.
A great way
to flat-pack consumables
and take them on the go.
And when they're finished,
simply zip up the contents
and throw it into the cooler,
fridge, or cupboard.
Or if it's empty, into the trash
or recycling bin.
Wait a minute.
No more cleanup?
No more cleanup!
(laughs)
The picnic, potluck,
and tailgate
will never be the same.
Or how about a convenient way to
get pasta sauce from the stove
to a bag? Ooh!
Ahh!
No more mismatched lids
for bulky plasticware.
(clatter)
Oh!
Ah. (laughs)
What an advantage for, say,
a chip or a peanut manufacturer
to utilize our technology
to offer their customers
an exclusive way
to turn the bag into a bowl.
Yeah! Or How about pioneering
a single-serving
dog food product?
Woof! Woof!
Now you're talking, bro.
(sharks laugh)
Bag bowl brings convenience,
function, and style
to modern living.
Our humble goal is to change
the way the world consumes.
Who wants to join us and be
a new Fleming brother or sister
and help us take the bag bowl
global?
Can we see it?
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
Here you guys go.
As you can see, it folds
totally flat when not in use.
Thank you, sir.
You're welcome. Thank you.
Does this come apart
right here?
No, that's
the ultrasonic weld.
Uh, it can be microwavable
with certain kind of polymers.
Guys, how much have you invested
to create this?
We've put in $40,000
of our own money.
But before the train gets
too far down the track,
well, let's tell you what
our plan is for this business.
We are looking at
a licensing play for bag bowl.
Brian and I were considering
manufacturing it.
When we looked
at all the resources
that was going to take,
we thought,
instead of shaking
one apple tree,
why not lease out
the entire orchard?
But isn't it a niche market?
Because I have a bowl already
in my home, all right?
So if I buy a bag of chips,
I pour them into the bowl.
The chip company is not going to
increase its cost by 20 cents
to provide one of these.
They already sell their chips
and they're successful.
Mm.
The guy who sells a bag of
anything is already selling it.
He doesn't need to provide
the service
to create a bowl for you.
Bowls are ubiquitous in homes.
This is for tailgating,
maybe.
I'm just not sure there's
a real demand for this.
I don't know if you've seen,
though,
where packaging is going
these days.
Everybody's wanting to be able
to eat right out of the package
that you're eating,
and right now
it's not an elegant process
because...
and that is the problem...
the top does not open up well.
Because you're pushing
the burden of the cost
back on the manufacturer,
and that's a trend that is--
They're not gonna like.
The cost does not--
We've talked--
We've talked to gigantic plastic
packaging manufacturers
in our homes--
and what did they say?
2 cents to add this structure
to the bag. It's negligible.
Listen, to the consumer goods
package business,
2 cents is a lot.
They hire people--
dozens of them--
To cut costs
by 1/8th of a cent.
But, I mean, look at the scale
of this business.
Do you guys know
how many plastic bags
are used in the country?
But what is to stop
somebody else
from just doing this?
We have a utility patent written
on the product, and, uh--
you have a utility patent
already issued?
No, we're
patent-pending still. Yeah.
It's pending.
That doesn't mean
it'll ever issue.
Ah.
What is the unique property,
though,
to patent
of a circle of plastic?
Um, well, as you know,
sometimes, uh, the best,
most ingenious patents
are sometimes
very simple innovations,
like the post-It note or the end
of the shoelace things--
Small things that in aggregate
make life a little bit easier.
Our patent is designed to be
a structural...
exoskeleton.
The exoskeleton for a plastic
bag to folds over the sides.
I mean, I think you guys
are great,
and I think this is
really clever.
I just don't think
that you're gonna get
any intellectual property
on it.
Where do you sell this? Are you
currently selling this anywhere?
We went to a trade show
in Chicago, the I.H.A. show,
which is one of the biggest
housewares shows in the world.
We know--we know what it is.
So everybody saw this?
Everybody has seen this.
Out of 2,000 booth spaces,
we were one of 30 that received
a prestigious award
called the design defined award.
People loved it.
The feedback was overwhelming
and tremendous.
Once people saw us do the flip,
everyone had that "Aha" Moment--
did you take orders?
How many people--Yeah,
how many orders did you get?
How many stores Wanted--
Uh, we just took feedback
from that.
We went to that show with
a proof of concept in mind.
You did not get orders.
The answer's "None.
But you won an award.
So was that romancing the truth
and just saying,
"No, we have no sales"?
(chuckles)
Well,
we're a pre-Revenue startup.
But, I mean, look at...
(laughter)
The scale of this business.
So it's actually
dancing around the truth...
yes. Yes.
Instead of saying,
"No, we have no sales."
No, we're at the beginning.
We're at the beginning.
It's a pre-Revenue startup.
Exactly!
Hey, the guy's being honest
with you.
(mark laughing)
Exactly.
So it's pre-order,
pre-revenue...
pre-patent.
Pre-does anybody want it?
Pre-order, pre-patent,
pre-everything.
Pre-calling somebody
to try to license it.
Right.
It's completely virgin snow,
and you guys are at
the top of the mountain,
and we can ski powder
all the way down.
You guys are slick, right?
You found a niche. How big
it could be is debatable,
but you guys are great
at debating it.
But it's all about making
somebody else do the work.
I see you guys
not as entrepreneurs
But as want-repreneurs.
Cubes, let me--
Let me jump in there.
"Cubes"?
Cubes? Just for calling me
"Cubes," I'm out.
I'm calling him "Cubes"
From now on.
We can get from "A" to "B,"
No doubt about it.
But we are here
at the Shark Tank
to get your access,
your expertise.
You guys have no sales,
uh, no patent,
no history, and you want us
to call on your behalf
and you want our friends
to call us morons
when we pitch all of what
you're saying to them. Right?
Well, we are--
We're not looking for you
to impugn your character.
And if you think that
that's the kind of ridicule
you would get
from your, you know,
pitching this to other people,
then, you know,
that would speak volumes
about the partnership
we could have.
And there's the bottom line.
So if I'm not running with it,
I'm running from it.
But--
I'm out.
I understand. Um...
I ain't mad at ya.
The greatest consumer
Innovations and products
and success stories and profits
and wealth
come from ideas that do
two things--
Solve Problems
and reduce costs.
Right.
This idea does neither.
(Daymond) Mm-hmm.
So... I'm out.
(mouths word)
Look, Brian,
h-Here's where I'm at.
Um...
I think it's very clever.
You know, I have little kids.
I think of the Tetra Pak.
I think the person who invented
a square and easy way
to drink juice boxes
made a lot of money
from something that was
no different--
Yeah, because it cut cost of
glass bottles, that's why.
No, they made--Oh,
and they made it easier.
I can see this selling.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you the $40,000
for 45%.
I'll help you with getting
a couple companies
to make a licensing deal.
And I think I can help you
get it off the ground.
Well, thank you. That, uh--
so you're saying
this 3-Inch hula-hoop
is worth $100,000 now,
the company?
You know,
I think it's a great idea
or It's not, but what I like
about it, Daymond, is we can...
so you'll take--
It's a flier?
You're gonna take a gamble
on it?
Make a couple of calls and we
can find out very quickly.
Can I get up and look?
Absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely.
Lori, are you interested?
I'm looking.
Why should she not be, Daymond?
She's attractive and she likes
attractive gentlemen.
(chuckles)
Keep sucking up.
So you just stick it down in...
yep.
And you just go like this?
Mm-hmm.
When you fold this over
the side of it,
it actually acts like
a-a ring around a barrel
and helps give it stability.
(Robert) Lori, how is it?
How--is it easy?
It's easy.
Thank you.
Uncle Ben's has a 90-second rice
that comes out of the microwave
in 90 seconds.
It's a great product but imagine
the Uncle Ben's product
being able to turn
into a bag itself
as opposed to the headache
that you create
pouring it into another bowl,
and then saying,
"now I have to wash that bowl."
I don't agree
with the licensing thing.
I think that if you show this
off and try to get it licensed
to a lot of companies,
they're just gonna knock it off.
I don't think you're gonna
get the patent.
But all that being said,
I can get products made,
into market,
and onto my show on QVC,
and sell hundreds of thousands
of dollars within minutes.
I think this is
a great tv item.
Last season,
I took a guy who came in
with a piece of steel
and a magnet,
and we've now done
almost $3 million in sales
in the last year.
I think it's possible
that we might be able to do some
Really big numbers with this.
That being said,
I will give you the $40,000
for the 33% stake
in the company.
What do you say?
You're gonna give them exactly
what they asked for, right?
I'm gonna give them exactly
what they asked for.
Could we have a minute to...
(Kevin and Robert
speak indistinctly)
she gave you what you offered.
What are you gonna discuss?
Yeah. Yeah, go have a minute.
See what happens.
Wow.
You're taking a huge risk
by walking out the door.
She gave you what
you asked for.
Guys, you walk out of here,
I'm pulling my offer.
It's amazing that you would even
stop for a minute...
no, we didn't--
no, I was just getting--
To think about it.
We would love to do
the deal with you, Lori.
Thank you.
Good.
Great.
Thank you.
It's so exciting.
Yeah, I'm very excited.
Great. Great to be working
with you.
I think it'll be great.
Thank you so much.
Great.
Whoo!
(Mark) Whoo-Hoo!
Talk to you soon.
Thank you, guys.
Yeah! (laughs)
(laughs)
Whoo!
Here's a little advice
for all the Mavericks players--
don't call him "Cubes."
(laughs)
The guy flips out.
We chummed the water,
and, uh, it looks like
we got a little bit nipped
in the leg a couple times.
But in the end, we swam
right out of there with a deal,
and we couldn't be
more stoked.
♪♪♪
Next is Henry Penix,
with technology he hopes
to get in the hands
of every household in America.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Henry penix,
and I'm the C.E.O. of Zomm.
I'm asking for $2 million...
Whoa.
For 10% of my entire company.
At Zomm, we create products
and services
that revolutionize what people
do with their cell phones.
And everyone has
a cell phone.
Have any of you all ever left
your phones behind somewhere
at a restaurant or bar or maybe
at home in the morning?
I have, too.
Well, when you put this
to your keychain
and it separates
from your phone,
it's gonna warn you that
you've walked away
and left your phone behind.
Let me show you how it works.
Mark, you mind holding this?
Sure.
Okay. All right, so say
you've--say you went home
and you're rushing out
to the office, grab your keys
'cause you gotta have your keys
to drive your car.
When you get about
20 or 30 feet away,
let me show you what happens.
I'm gonna step over here.
You should feel a vibration.
Yep. Sure do.
Yeah.
And it'll light up.
You can see it light up.
Sure does.
So if those two don't
get your attention,
an alarm will start.
(beeping gradually
increases volume)
And then it'll start getting
louder and louder
until you turn around...
until I come get my phone.
And get your phone. Yeah. Yeah.
So you can press the middle
button to turn it off.
(beeping stops)
Everything's one-Button press.
Very simple.
Very cool.
Uh-huh. Thank you.
The second thing that it does--
you can find your keys with it.
Let me do this.
(beep)
Uh, Daymond, do you mind
to hang onto this?
When I turn around,
pass it to somebody,
and then I'll figure out
who took it.
You got it?
(pinging sound)
I could tell by your eyes!
(laughs)
(speaks indistinctly)
(Lori) Sounds like a submarine.
(laughs)
The depth of the undertaker.
(pinging stops)
So, um, the next thing
that it does--
It's actually
an emergency dialer.
You can program any number
in it.
I've put my wife's number
(phone rings)
(woman)
Hey, are you in trouble?
I may be. I'm swimming
with sharks right now.
All right,
talk to you later.
So this is
the modern-day version
of "I've fallen
and I can't get up!"
Well, yeah. Yeah, it has
that aspect to it as well.
We've had a lot of people
buy it for that.
Well, I've seen this
in similar ways before.
I've seen a dog collar
Where if your pet goes too far,
your phone rings.
Is it
all the elements combined
that makes this so special
or worth $20 million? Or...
it is. Yeah, we've got patents
all over the world,
uh, won innovation awards
the last three years.
So tell us about your sales,
your costs, your margins,
what it's being sold for,
et cetera.
When we first came out with it
in late 2010,
we did about $750,000
in sales.
What were your sales in 2011?
We did right at $5 million.
(Kevin) Ah.
Whoa.
Good growth.
And what are you on track for
this year?
Uh, about $7.2 million.
Nice.
And will you net
when you do $7.2 million?
Yeah, I'm glad you asked.
Me, too.
This is the exciting part.
(chuckles)
We will net, uh,
right at $2 million,
after--
This is after all of your costs,
paying yourself,
all your employees?
Yes.
Are you gonna spend
that $2 million also,
put it back in the business?
Because you basically have
the $2 million
you're asking for.
I've never taken a salary
from the company.
Uh, I've actually put money
in the company myself.
Uh--
how much?
Uh, I put in, um,
right at $4 million.
(Robert and Daymond)
Of your own money?
Yeah. Yeah.
(Kevin) And how much
do you own of it?
Well, you'd get
that money from?
I, uh, in 2000,
I sold a business
that my wife and I
had built.
We built it from zero
to about 300 employees,
and we were able to exit--
what kind of business?
Uh, it was, uh,
early learning centers.
Do you own the company yourself?
I do.
(Kevin) 100%?
(Lori) With no partners?
100%?
No, no.
We've got one other investor.
They're in at, uh, 17%.
And how much did they put in?
$5 million.
(Kevin) Whoa.
So this is a down round for you,
basically?
Excuse me?
A "down round" meaning
$5 million for 17%
values the company
at about $30 million.
Yeah, why are you going down?
Because we need the cash
right now.
Hang on. You put in $4 million
of your own.
You go out,
you raise another $5 million,
giving the company
about a $30 million value.
Your numbers are on fire,
fantastic growth.
And you're running out of cash?
Yeah.
(Lori) Why are you running out
of cash?
Something smells
a little funny here.
The other part is we actually
developed another product.
Ah!
We've developed
a product that
we won three innovation awards
just this past January.
And it's not this?
No.
It's called
Lifestyle Connect,
and it does everything
that this does
but it will monitor--like,
low energy heart rate monitors,
blood glucose monitors,
and fall detectors.
But let me ask. You--
(Robert) But, Henry, you--
You've raised $9 million,
how do you burn through
$9 million in...
two years?
Can you explain that to me?
♪♪♪
You've raised $9 million.
How do you burn through
$9 million in...
two years?
Can you explain that to me?
We've got some inventory
as well.
(Kevin) How much inventory?
How much you have in inventory?
We've got close to $2 million
in inventory.
The numbers
just don't add up for me.
They don't add up because
if your sales are that strong,
you shouldn't be holding
$2 million in inventory.
Exactly.
We built, last year,
a little too much
for the Christmas season,
and we didn't sell through
all of them.
So what's happening now--You
guys tell me if I'm wrong here--
You got too excited
during the Christmas season,
you built too many.
Now you've got this big crush
of inventory,
and you think your solution is
to go out and raise $2 million
so you can get out
from underneath your inventory
and get to your new product.
Continue this product and...
(Daymond)
but wait, wait, wait.
We'll--We'll decide if we want
to bring the new product.
But wait, there's more.
I'm like a bloodhound.
Let me--Let me ask you
something.
How much did you spend on R&D--
Research and development?
All the money that we've
ever invested in the company
we've put back
into the company.
I didn't get the answer.
Just, how much do you think
you spend in R&D
over the last three years?
I don't know
the exact number.
Would you say that you spent
about a million... or more?
I really don't know
the exact number.
You can--You had $9 million.
You gotta know where it went.
Yeah, you should--I mean,
a million between friends...
you gotta know.
I get it. But... under a million
or over a million?
I would say over.
(Mark and Daymond) Okay.
(Mark) When you got started,
did you go through the approach
of go and hire
some marketing M.D.A.S,
put together
a marketing program?
Marketing guys, sales guys.
And you raised
all this money
because it was go big
or go home?
Yeah. Yeah, we--
and you guys wanted
to hit the home run,
and you got a triple...
(laughs)
Yeah. Yeah.
But now you're stuck.
Steve jobs had a dream.
He wanted a computer
on every desktop.
And my dream is to have a Zomm
or a Zomm product
with every cell phone.
And your dream is killing you.
You went too big
and tried to hit a home run
when a single would
win the game.
Yeah.
And that's why I'm out.
You sure?
I'm positive.
You've done two things
most people have never done
that get in front of us.
You've raised $9 million
and you've done $5 million
in sales,
and your company is basically
about to die,
and you don't even know it.
I gotta tell ya, I wouldn't give
you $2 million of my own money.
I'm out.
I have to take my hat off to
you, creating a great business.
But I think that
if I go into your books,
it's gonna be horrific.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Lori?
Yeah?
Mr. Wonderful?
I think what you've done
is brilliant.
I think it's a great product.
Problem for me is that
where you are right now,
needing to ask us for money,
it tells me something's wrong.
And for that reason, I'm out.
Okay, Henry, I'm the last shark
still looking at this.
What intrigues me are sales,
and you have them.
But... I don't think I'm gonna
give you $2 million.
All I care about is when
I part with my money
and send it off to summer camp
to go and train
and learn a new skill, is that
it comes back in September
with a lot more muscles.
I'm scared
you'll kill my money.
I won't kill your money.
You've killed a lot of money
before mine.
Take--Take the majority
of the board seats.
I don't want to take control.
I really don't.
Let's--Let's figure it out.
Although--although you could
use me, believe me.
I could fix you in--in
darwinian ways you don't know,
but you may not find that
a pleasant experience.
I'm out.
Good luck.
Okay. All right,
thank you very much.
Bye-Bye.
(Mark) He just went big.
If he were to come
into the Shark Tank
the day he started and said,
"Guys, I need help. I want
$250,000 for 25% of my company,"
We'd have been all over it.
(Robert)
You know, it's a shame there.
(Lori) It's a great product.
That was a great product.